corona lähmt die konjunktur deutschlands
wirtschaft schrumpft um über 2 prozent
und steht vor einer schweren rezession
ausschluss aus der afd der brandenburger
landeschef andreas kalbitz muss wegen
rechtsextremer kontakte die partei
verlassen einmal fahrverbot und wieder
zurück die härteren strafen für raser
will verkehrsminister scheuer wieder
kippen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers die welt an diesem
freitag schön dass sie dabei sind guten
abend hinein ein freitag der wieder -
zahlen aus der wirtschaft bereit hält
deutschland ist in eine rezession
gerutscht durch die korona krise es
könnte der anfang sein der schweiz
schwersten rezession der
nachkriegsgeschichte
am ende des ersten quartals steht ein
minus von 2,2 prozent im vergleich zu
den drei monaten zuvor
und das obwohl der korona ausbruch die
deutsche wirtschaft im januar und
februar noch unbeeindruckt ließ erst mit
den strengen maßnahmen im märz ging es
bergab
und deshalb rechnen volkswirte damit
dass es im zweiten quartal dieses jahres
noch mal deutlich schlimmer wird
christina hansen jetzt aus hamburg sie
kommen jeden tag containerriesen aus der
ganzen welt aber es kommen immer weniger
rund 500 frachtschiffe sind weltweit im
moment aus dem verkehr gezogen worden
der umschlag geht deutlich zurück der
welthandel ist ins stocken geraten
im ersten quartal wurden im hamburger
hafen 7,9 prozent weniger güter
umgeschlagen
der hafen ist als handelsdrehscheibe
auch ein indikator für die entwicklung
der exportorientierten wirtschaft in
deutschland
die wirtschaft schrumpft befindet sich
am anschlag viele unternehmen das heißt
wir werden davon ausgehen müssen dass
das jahr 2020 außerordentlich
herausfordernd wird für die gesamte
deutsche wirtschaft nicht nur für jene
teile die vom shutdown unmittelbar
betroffen sind ein lichtblick für die
zweite jahreshälfte
der so wichtige handel mit china gewinnt
wieder an fahrt dafür gibt es weniger im
und exporte mit anderen ländern wie zum
beispiel den usa häufig sind
lieferketten in der eng vernetzten
weltwirtschaft unterbrochen
die deutsche industrie ist auf rohstoffe
und produktionsteile aus der ganzen welt
angewiesen wir sind mit hochdruck dabei
internationalen lieferketten wieder
herzustellen
das tun wir gemeinsam mit den
unternehmen jetzt wo wir aus der groner
pandemie langsam wieder herausfinden
auch um die konjunkturprogramme brauchen
wir anreize für diejenigen die wieder
loslegen wollen aktuell wächst die sorge
vor einer zweiten corona welle vor allem
in china ein erneutes herunterfahren der
produktion
dort würde die weltwirtschaft noch mehr
belasten wir bleiben noch bei schlechten
nachrichten aus der wirtschaft die
angeschlagene warenhauskette galeria
kaufhof plant offenbar harte einschnitte
80 von insgesamt gut 170 filialen droht
die schließung
so steht das in verschiedenen
medienberichten wir fragen nach bei
frank bethmann an der frankfurter börse
frank guten abend das klingt jetzt nach
ziemlichem kahlschlag bei karstadt
kaufhof was ist der auslöser
ausschließlich corona oder doch mehr
naja sagen wir es mal so durch corona
ist die bahn hausgeräte jedenfalls noch
sehr viel stärker in schieflage geraten
als sie das ohnehin schon war bereits
mit krisenbeginn war karstadt kaufhof
nicht mehr in der lage seine geschäfte
alleine zu führen flow unter einen
schutzschirm nun fehlen auch noch die
umsätze der letzten acht wochen darunter
auch das wichtige ostergeschäft die sich
langsam wieder erfüllen den
fußgängerzonen kommen offenbar für viele
filialen zu spät mehr als 500 millionen
euro umsatz sind bereits verloren
gegangen
und so soll sich die von außen
eingesetzte geschäftsleitung heute wohl
dazu gezwungen bittere wahrheiten
internen auszusprechen ohne
filialschließungen und entlassungen
ginge es nicht 5000 vollzeitstellen
sollen da angebliche wegfallen
karstadt kaufhof wollte das heute nicht
bestätigen die gewerkschaft verdi aber
die ist auf 180 und unterstellt eben
genau das
da wird corona benutzt um einzelne
warenhäuser platt zu machen fragt
herzlichen dank nach frankfurt und wie
schlagen sich diese zahlen und diese
nachrichten aus der wirtschaft nieder
bei uns allen dafür haben wir wie immer
freitags das neue zdf politbarometer und
matthias fornoff genommen hat ihn so
genannt und versagen denn die deutschen
zu ihrer wirtschaftlichen lage
bei dieser kritischen großwetterlage
unter den bedingungen von corona mit
verheerenden daten aus der wirtschaft
wir haben es gerade gehört steuerloch
kurzarbeit bleiben die deutschen doch
eher gelassen was die eigene situation
angeht
meine wirtschaftliche lage hat sich sehr
stark verschlechtert sagen nur vier
prozent stark verschlechtert 7 prozent
meine lage hat sich nicht so stark
verschlechtert 20 prozent und mehr als
zwei drittel sagen dass sich die eigene
lage gar nicht verschlechtert hat 23
die eigene lage hat sich gar nicht
verschlechtert das wundert dann doch
schon ein bisschen angesichts dieser
hiobsbotschaften aus der wirtschaft oder
diese werte sind interessanterweise sehr
stabil auch auf lange sicht selbst in
der finanzkrise 2008 war die
einschätzung der eigenen lage ähnlich
und man darf auch nicht ganz vergessen
dass nur gut die hälfte der deutschen
überhaupt berufstätig ist und was sagen
die leute zum krisenmanagement der
politik es gibt nach wie vor viel
zustimmung zu den corona maßnahmen 17
prozent der deutschen finden die
maßnahmen zwar übertrieben für zwei
drittel aber sind sie genau richtig und
15 prozent wünschen sich sogar einen
noch strengeren kurs die korona krise
hat die politische landschaft kräftig
durchgeschüttelt das neue bild
stabilisiert sich jetzt wenn am sonntag
bundestagswahl wäre käme die union auf
38 prozent die spd auf 15 beide - einst
die afg 10 +1 fdp fünf unverändert linke
8 +1 und grüne 18 prozent unverändert
über monate gab es im politbarometer
keine mehrheit für die amtierende
regierung jetzt würde es reichen sowohl
für schwarz grün als auch für
schwarz-rot spannende zahlen matthias
vielen dank und das komplette
politbarometer heute abend im
heute-journal oder jetzt schon online
hofft zdf heute.de und wir bleiben in
der politik bei der afd
da gibt es einen paukenschlag der
bundesvorstand hat heute über den fall
andreas kalbitz beraten und entschieden
der brandenburger hfd landes und
fraktionschef wird aus der partei
ausgeschlossen
hintergrund sind kontakte zur inzwischen
verbotenen neonazi organisation
heimattreue deutsche jugend christian
hübscher und david gebhard berichten 7
afd vorstandsmitglieder waren gegen ihn
fünf für ihn eine enthaltung andreas
kalbitz ist raus muss die partei
verlassen
das ist ja nicht das ende der
veranstaltung also das ist jetzt erst
mal sehen ich werde alle rechtsmittel
ausschöpfen
ich bedauere dass teile des
bundesvorstandes sich offensichtlich zu
handlangern der politischen gegner und
des verfassungsschutzes gemacht haben
damit ist vor allem er gemeint
parteivorsitzender meuten hatte die
abstimmung über kalbitz verlangt wir
haben in einer sehr ernsthaften auch
kontroversen das wissen sie diskussion
die rechtliche frage gewürdigt ob die
bedingungen die zur aufnahme von hell
bis zum jahr 2013 führten rechtlich
korrekt waren oder nicht
und wir sind zu dem ergebnis gekommen
mehrheitlich sie sind es nicht und haben
daraus die konsequenzen gezogen
kalbitz hatte der partei seine früheren
kontakte ins rechtsextreme milieu
verschwiegen
dann tauchten belege auf fotos die in
2007 beim pfingstlager der heimattreuen
deutschen jugend zeigen
inzwischen ist der verein verboten der
bundesverfassungsschutz zitiert in einem
bericht die mitgliederliste der hdj von
damals unter der mitgliedsnummer 1 0 13
30 die familie andreas kalbitz kalbitz
hat den verfassungsschutz auf herausgabe
des dokuments verklagt der brandenburger
war neben dem thüringer höcke
prominentester vertreter des
rechtsextremen flügels der afg der sich
ende april offiziell aufgelöst hat die
heutige entscheidung des vorstands aber
wird zur zerreißprobe für die gesamte
partei das ergebnis für falsch und für
gefährlich für die partei
und glaube auch nicht dass es juristisch
auch alice weidl und co parteichef
kubala hätten die vorwürfe lieber noch
weiter geprüft doch sie wurden
überstimmt
damit verliert der brandenburger
landesverband seinen chef kalbitz die
dortige landtagsfraktion auch ohne
parteibuch weiterführen kann entscheidet
sich nächste woche gucken auch für
moment hinter die kulissen des ganzen
und zwar mit theo koll auch heute abend
wieder unserem hauptstadtstudio leiter
theo wer hat sich da jetzt durchgesetzt
in der afc haben sich ganz klar die
etwas weniger radikalen kräfte in der
afg rund um jörg neuten durchgesetzt
andreas kalbitz war der eigentliche kopf
des ultrarechten oder auch
rechtsnationalen teils der partei dieser
sogenannte flügel wurde vom
bundesverfassungsschutz als
rechtsextremistische bestrebungen
eingestuft hatte sich offiziell zum 30
april aufgelöst aber verfassungsschützer
sind sehr skeptisch geblieben ob dem zu
trauen ist der rauswurf von kalbitz
aufgrund von verschiedenen kontakten
werden es gerade gehört zu der
verbotenen hdj ist sicher auch als
signal richtung verfassungsschutz zu
verstehen interessanterweise hatten sich
die drei anderen führungsfiguren der afg
gauland weidl und kubala für kalbitz
ausgesprochen sind aber heute überstimmt
worden
du hast gesagt da gibt es also einiges
an streit auch in der afg was heißt das
jetzt für die generelle linie der afd in
zukunft also der rauswurf von gallwitz
dürfte in der afg zu schweren
verwerfungen führen denn der radikalere
teil der partei ist ja damit nicht
verschwunden
der vorsitzende der fdp landtagsfraktion
in sachsen anhaltischen im vorfeld
kommentiert ich zitiere kallwitz aus der
partei zu entfernen entfernt dieser
partei das rückgrat und den schneid den
diese partei so dringend nötig hat die
heutige entscheidung fiel mit 7 zu 5
stimmen und das zeigt dann auch die
ganze zerrissenheit der partei also die
afd dürfte mit dem rauswurf von kallwitz
in schwere turbulenzen geraten
die analyse von theo koll dankeschön
nach berlin und auch unser nächstes
thema treibt viele um es geht um die
frage wie sehr der kampf gegen das virus
unsere gesellschaft verändert
und uns möglicherweise zurückwirft in
alte rollenbilder erste forscher warnen
dass die krise bei der
gleichberechtigung von frauen alte
probleme besonders sichtbar macht und
sie sogar verschärft denn corona trifft
berufstätige mütter noch mal ganz
besonders wie ihre schüler berichtet sie
waren einmal eine moderne familie beide
berufstätig die betreuung der drei
kinder fair aufgeteilt doch in der
korona krise hat sich das traditionelle
rollenmuster eingeschlichen
andrea rupp kinder haushalt
homeschooling und irgendwie ihren job
als agenturchefin während ihr mann
morgens das haus verlässt weil er
hauptverdiener ist die belastungen der
familie vor allem dann mit wenn ich
merke wie meine frau letztendlich auf
dem zahnfleisch geht und ich habe kaum
die möglichkeit habe sie zu unterstützen
ich glaube das ist gerade extremist
minivan der rolle rückwärts machen in
sachen emanzipation weil auf einmal
wieder ganz klar die frauen die rolle
einnehmen oder auch einnehmen müssen
seitdem lockt und verbringen väter etwa
9% zeit mehr mit ihren kindern bei
müttern sind es 36 prozent
in der krise verschärft sich was vorher
schon war beobachtet soziologin
allmendinger dann sehen wir dass frauen
ihre arbeitszeit sehr reduziert werden
um 24 prozent im durchschnitt
und das wäre jetzt vielleicht noch gar
nicht so beängstigend error frauen
arbeiten hier sowieso wesentlich eher
als männer in teilzeit die regierung
muss handeln schulen und kindergärten
schneller öffnen fordert
geschäftsführerin und mutter christina
sontheim leben
sie hat eine petition gestartet wir
werden uns in ein zwei jahren fragen wo
bitte sind denn all die weiblichen
führungskräfte und dann wird uns einfach
ach ja stimmt die sind ja zum teil noch
im home office oder die sind aus der
ganzen karriere schiene ausgestiegen die
haben nämlich in der zeit mit den
kindern zu hause geknetet und den
männern den rücken frei gehalten dass
freizeitparks öffnen schulen und
kindergärten aber nur langsam in den
normalbetrieb gehen macht auch andrea
reifen in der krise wird verspielt was
frauen über jahrzehnte erkämpft haben
findet sie
wie corona die debatte um die
geschlechterrollen neu entfacht mehr
heute abend in aspekte zdf 23 uhr und
noch eine wichtige nachricht deutschland
lockert weiter wer aus dem eu ausland
oder aus schengen staaten zurück nach
deutschland kommt muss nicht mehr für
zwei wochen in quarantäne
in nordrhein westfalen und rheinland
pfalz gilt dass bereits andere
bundesländer wollen nachziehen
und dann gucken wir dieser stelle in der
sendung auf die zahl die aktuell am
meisten interessiert die neuinfektionen
im durchschnitt der letzten sieben tage
gingen die noch einmal deutlich zurück
auf 720 ansteckungen täglich insgesamt
sind damit mehr als 100 74.000
infektionen durch tests bestätigt davon
gelten mehr als 151.000 betroffene als
genesen und sieben 1884 menschen sind
gestorben in verbindung mit 19
was diese und andere zahlen rund um
corona aussagen wo aber auch die
probleme mit den zahlen liegen dass
finden sie interaktiv erklärt in der
zdf- heute- app zum durchklicken die
wichtigsten zahlen und ihre bedeutung
und jetzt weitere wichtige themen von
heute das bundesverfassungsgericht
bekommt einen neuen präsidenten
stephan harbarth bisher bisher
vizepräsident in karlsruhe rückt an die
spitze des höchsten deutschen gerichts
dafür stimmte der bundesrat seit 2018
ist stephan harbarth verfassungsrichter
vorher saß der frühere wirtschaftsanwalt
für die cdu im bundestag
er löst andreas voßkuhle hat dessen
amtszeit endet die rechtsprofessorin
astrid wallrabenstein übernimmt die
freie richterstelle
im zweiten senat kehrtwende im
verkehrsministerium die strengeren
regeln für autoraser könnten bald doch
nicht mehr gelten heißt es gerade einmal
zweieinhalb wochen nachdem sie auf druck
der länder eingeführt wurden
stellt sich die frage was ist da
schiefgelaufen eigentlich besagt neue
verordnung wer innerorts mehr als 21 km
h zu schnell fährt bekommt ein monat
fahrverbot
außerhalb ab 26 km h zu schnell
das ist zu hart finden vor allem jene
die beruflich ihren führerschein
brauchen und deren klagen will der
verkehrsminister
jetzt offenbar
dort war aber über ein bemerkenswertes
hin und her ist das tempo zu hoch ist
der führerschein gleich für einen monat
weg
so will es die neue
straßenverkehrsordnung der widerstand
dagegen ist groß eine online petition
hat weit mehr als 100.000 unterzeichner
und der adac sagt wer eine 30er zone
übersieht und deshalb mit 51 km h dort
rein fährt ist noch nicht der raser der
mit einem fahrverbot ein denkzettel
braucht die geschichte mit den
fahrverboten bei geschwindigkeit die
muss jetzt geändert werden
führerscheinverlust sei
unverhältnismäßig findet jetzt auch der
verkehrsminister und plädiert für eine
kehrtwende
politik muss auch die kraft haben das
verständnis aufzubringen für die
bürgerinnen und bürger die sich bei uns
melden und sagen macht es wieder in den
alten stand zurück da muss die politik
auch die kraft haben das wieder zu
verändern nicht führerschein weg sondern
erhöhtes bußgeld etwa 100 statt 80 euro
so schoss vorstellung für die rolle
rückwärts gibt es auch kritik überhöhte
geschwindigkeit sei eines der größten
todes und verletzungsrisiken
argumentiert die gewerkschaft der
polizei saß vorstoß wird überall heftig
diskutiert viele sind einfach mit der
arbeit auf das auto angewiesen
und dann vier wochen lang theoretisch
gar nicht zur arbeit zu kommen also ich
fahre jeden tag 35 km die leute die hier
etwas durch die gegend tragen sage ich
mal
ich glaube tatsächlich fahrverbot würde
sie mehr treffen als ein bußgeld die
kurze aussehende kartoffel ist auch das
allerletzte aber so funktioniert politik
der verkehrsminister allein kann die
regeln nicht ändern
er ist dabei auf die unterstützung der
länder angewiesen
die muss er jetzt überzeugen und jetzt
gucken wir dorthin wo es in europa immer
noch die meisten corona fälle gibt nach
großbritannien
dort sind aktuell rund 238.000
infektionen erfasst und die meisten
todesfälle mehr als 34.000 besonders
schlimm trifft es die pflegeheime
nirgendwo sonst außer in krankenhäusern
sterben im moment mehr briten tätiger
sagen die regierung hat die hilferufe
der schwächsten und schutzbedürftigsten
ignoriert dass interline berichtet aus
london
nur durch ein leicht geöffnetes fenster
kann diese frau mit ihrem vater in einem
altenheim in burnley kommunizieren er
liegt im sterben weil jedoch nicht
genügend tests erhältlich sind ist nicht
bekannt ob es cupid 19 ist und niemand
aus der familie darf ihn besuchen ich
mir das herz so darf das nicht sein
durch ein fenster großbritanniens
versäumnisse beim umgang mit dem corona
virus werden vor allem im alten
pflegesektor deutlich und ein viertel
aller todesfälle hat sich dort ereignet
es mangelt an schutzkleidung und test
kapazitäten wir wurden alleingelassen
als hätte man uns vergessen uns genauso
wie die heiminsassen im märz hatte die
regierung noch verkündet es gebe
keinerlei probleme in den pflegeheimen
doch es ist möglich dass beim bemühen
krankenhäuser für patienten zu räumen
infizierte in altenheime entlassen
wurden all dies führt zu der befürchtung
dass die todeszahlen dem land inzwischen
die höchsten in europa noch viel höher
liegen als die zahlen der regierung
verraten die opposition erhöht zunimmt
den druck auf premierminister johnson
wie sechste mal der oppositionsführer
versucht vergleichen mit anderen
anzuziehen die wie ich mir habe sagen
lassen vor einig sind nicht ich ziehe
hier vergleiche die regierung hat kruse
ländervergleiche selbst benutzt sie aber
jetzt wo wir den unheilvollen
europäischen spitzenplatz einem
plötzlich fallen lassen
eine traurige bilanz die vor allem auch
dem umgang mit der seit langem
vernachlässigten altenpflege geschuldet
ist und jetzt nach mallorca auf die
insel auf der millionen deutsche jedes
jahr urlaub machen und auch im corona
jahr haben da fehle noch hoffnung
im moment allerdings geht noch nichts
mehr aus dem ausland nach spanien kommt
muss dort erst einmal für zwei wochen in
quarantäne
auf den balearen wächst die sorge vor
den wirtschaftlichen folgen wenn die
touristen ausbleiben thomas walde
draußen geht wieder was in palma de
mallorca weniger corona infektionen
heißt lokale dürfen die hälfte der
plätze besetzen wir öffnen wieder am 20
mai also kommenden mittwoch wir haben
viele anfragen weil einfach viele gäste
seiner kulinarischen rahmen zu aus
erlebt haben mehr als 13 millionen
internationale besucher kommen sonst im
jahr
jetzt braucht kein tourist informationen
und 140.000 menschen sind in kurzarbeit
wie diese kellnerin ehrlich gesagt
befürchten wir das schlimmste das alles
für fremde geschlossen bleibt und
niemand her kommen darf und wenn sie
kommen dürfen dann müssen sie 14 tage in
quarantäne
genau das hat die zentralregierung
gerade für einreisende angeordnet doch
örtliche behörden verlangen dass das
nicht für ausländer gilt bei denen es zu
hause auch wenige infektionen gibt
malaga jahren sind eine sichere region
ihre hausaufgaben gemacht hat und
natürlich befürworten wir eine direkte
einreise möglichkeit besonders aus den
ländern wie deutschland unseren
hauptkunden quarantäne droht auch
tausenden deutschen die hier wohnungen
besitzen und einreisen wollen um sie
kümmert sich peter berg auf wir haben
jeden tag neue anfragen von kunden aus
deutschland und auch aus england die
gerne hätten dass wir nach ihren
immobilien gucken
insofern hat sich das sehr positiv
entwickelt fürs geschäft doch das ist
die ausnahme die balearen hoffen nun
dass die eu reise freundliche regeln
findet in den sich auch die spanische
zentralregierung und schließt mallorca
wetter auch bei unserem wochenende wird
wärmer und ali hat gleich alle details
dazu
ich empfehle ihnen das heute journal mit
der kollegin marietta slomka um 22 uhr
und das gesamte team 19 bedankt sich für
ihr großes interesse morgen freut sich
hier petra gerster auf sie machen sie
sich alle ein angenehmer abend
[Musik]
ein schon genannte und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter eine
hochdruckbrücke breitet sich richtung
osten aus und dehnt sich dabei auch
gleichzeitig nach norden und süden und
es gibt es im norden regen und auch im
süden dazwischen wird es trocken bleiben
in der nacht also an der nordsee etwas
regen sonst ist es meist sternenklar
temperaturen am kältesten im vogtland
mit minus 1 grad oder mildesten an der
nordsee mit plus 8 grad
morgen ziehen im norden kompakte wolken
durch und einzelne chance und dabei
sonst ist es überall trocken nur an den
alpen
da gibt es einzelne schauer temperaturen
erreichen dort zwölf grad und im
südwesten 21 grad an den küsten sind es
13 bis 14 grad
ja und die nächsten tage haben sonntag
im norden noch schauer ansonsten
sonniges wetter bis 22 grad und ab
montag wird es deutlich wärmer bis 25
grad im norden noch einzelne schauer
dienstag komplett trocken damit ein
schöner abend